so sitting immediately to my right who
you've seen earlier today where she gave
a wonderful presentation talking about
the the night news challenge of where
this she's one is the wonderful doing in
New York Gillian wanted me to mention
that she is in no way prepared for this
discussion because she found that about
nine o'clock this morning when I pulled
her aside and asked her if she would
participate that said Gillian is
generally speaking one of the world's
best prepared people for this discussion
she heads up international advocacy and
international programs international
freedom of expression for the e FF has
worked on international advocacy and
freedom of expression for a long long
time in global voices in another context
and we're thrilled to have you here
thank you to further to your left to my
right is Nathan free to us the
benevolent dictator of the Guardian
project and I'm glad that you called
that out early on it's it's good to take
ownership of these sorts of things I'm
the guy with the mic that's all I always
got a certain amount of dictatorship
associated with it also deeply involved
with the Tibet action Institute someone
who has been coding and working through
issues of freedom of expression online
since before he was a teenager
someone who's thought really deeply
about these issues from a technology
perspective and finally on the end our
dear friend Emily Bell from The Tao
Center at Columbia Journalism school
formerly with a different Guardian
project the pioneering British newspaper
whereas she was the head of digital
content and one of the reasons basically
in general if I can put Emily on stage
and on a panel I do so but specifically
in this case wanted to have her here so
that we could talk through some of the
implications of surveillance for the
journalism community which was something
that we were both involved with an open
letter and the Tao Center is now very
very involved with questions of
journalism post Snowden
we're not going to back up and do the
entire Snowden revelations here it's
been an incredible year
and I'm guessing that most everyone in
the room has at least a cursory
familiarity with the story what we're
going to try to do instead is have a
conversation about questions of the
world post Snowden in terms of what does
this mean for activists what does this
mean for anyone trying to protect their
communication through technical channels
what does this mean for journalists and
for sources what does this mean for any
of us who are interested in trying to
use the digital public sphere as a space
where we can organize and where we can
debate and so because she's had such a
lousy day I thought I would start with
Emily and sort of ask if you can talk a
little bit about this question that we
found ourselves addressing in this open
letter
what do we think the Snowden revelations
mean for journalists and for their
sources ok tanks I was speeding
I was detained cuz I ran into somebody
and it was my fault I know you're not
supposed to say it was my fault in
America by British so it's like I'm
sorry that was my fault
and also if you're gonna run in someone
running someone nice preferably another
woman
so we chatted I charged her phone she
was like doesn't matter you take my car
sorry back to the issue in hands which
is what are these wrote what does these
revelations mean for the journalism
community well as Khai mean we can give
us some detail in a minute because they
were very specific I think security
implications which most journalists
including as we said Glenn Greenwald who
was the recipient of the leaks simply
weren't aware of they didn't kind of
practice good digital security there are
a small number of journalists who are
forced to practice digital security
because they are you know working in
extremely challenged very physically
dangerous environments but they're a
tiny percentage and in general I think
the journalism community pre Snowden two
things one of which was you know it's
it's actual newsroom practices in terms
of digital source protection we're very
poor and this is something that we oh
great deal of debt already too
activists you know from the FF etc Chris
Saroyan who pointed out sort of you know
two years ago in an op-ed in The New
York Times because it's saying
journalists need to kind of read each
sort of brain up on this kind of stuff
but I think there's a broader
implication as well which was something
that I've been concerned about for quite
some time even even when I was still
kind of operationally working at the
Guardian which is that we had this kind
of as journalists we had this sort of
almost inappropriately close
relationship with the technology into
the strays that there was a kind of an
outsourcing not just a function but also
of thought to Silicon Valley like you
would go rat like people with every time
I met a major kind of you know some
chief executive or director general of
this all that major media organization
they would always be I've just been out
Palo Alto and I've met Facebook and
Google and Google great and I didn't you
know I don't want to kind of come over
all if Jenny Morris off about this
because I because there are clearly
experiences you know that there's great
of expediency for journalism in using
freely available tools but there was
literally I think in many many cases no
thought about what this really meant and
the great thing about you know Snowden's
bravery and here's kind of you know
light on on how these relationships work
is that they really did demonstrate
vividly for journalists not just how
they needed to protect themselves and
their sources but how systems of power
you know work now and particularly in
the nature of big data and extensible
social platforms and even if you are not
going to you know be working with highly
sensitive information I don't think you
can be an effective journalist these
days unless you know exactly what those
issues are unless you understand those
systems and you understand that
journalism should stand apart from those
systems so some of the kind of you know
great things that I was not reading my
tweets season when I ran into that woman
but some of those great things that were
you know
tweeted about today in terms of civic
certificate activity and participation
you know journalism is the Fourth Estate
for a really good reason you know we're
not on anybody's side with there to hold
power to account we're there to go to
jail you know we're there to break the
law
when we see that things are wrong and
we're there to uphold freedom for
expression for not just ourselves but
other citizens as well and I think that
so I think there are - as I say there
are two sides to this one of which is a
much broader question and one of which
is a very specific security question and
we're addressing both of them in this
great sort of program which actually
Eaton was a real inspiration for called
journalism after Snowden you know shout
out to the sponsors night and Tara
Foundation of both backing it which
again is fantastic because we need
funding for tools and exploration in
this area because it's been you know
underfunded for too long and we're up
against a lot of money from some serious
actors in this so let's let's turn over
to Nate and and and let's talk a little
bit about the tools in the space because
you and my opinion have sort of taken on
a problem that's critically important
but also be incredibly challenging I
think many people in this room carrying
around mobile phones don't understand
that those of us sort of within the
human rights and activist community
think of these first and foremost as
tracking devices and then possibly later
as communication devices
what's the Guardian project trying to do
how far are you on it and and and how
has this sort of real and present danger
in the Snowden revelations that have
changed how you're thinking about that
space I think the issue of trust is now
at the forefront of people's minds
around what is the technology that I've
entrusted my freedom or voice or culture
or movement to and and that has been a
window through which to start getting
people to think about these tracking
devices in their pockets so the work
we've we're doing began out of my work
within the Tibetan independent
and rights movement we're supporting
Tibetans on the ground in China and
Tibet and in protest situations it
became apparent how much these were
tracking devices and how they were being
used to map a social graph and then
arrest lots of people very quickly so
when I began talking about this the only
secure phone mobile you could get cost
quite a bit of money and was being used
by military government contractors oil
companies things like this and so on the
large scale the progress that we've made
along with groups like open whisper
systems and other projects that have
thought about this is huge I mean you
can now take an off-the-shelf hundred
dollar smartphone pretty much anywhere
in the world and install free
open-source tools for like tour so I
work on tour on smartphones mic tegus is
here who does onion browser tour for
iPhones encrypted chat encrypted calling
and it's all free and it's works that's
great the I think the question comes
down to a lot of people is why should I
trust you
versus trusting Google or Twitter and
that's one that we're still trying to
sort out as small scrappy open-source
projects that aren't quite Mozilla yet
and I know Mozilla has a lot of and the
mark brought up a great point about app
stores and this is this is one of the
biggest issues I think right now is we
can build all the apps we want but we
have this barrier of the App Store which
is for places like China is a huge
problem and so because the gatekeepers
are not the open web we we we are a
little screwed in some cases but I want
to talk about that more because because
that's part of it it's just how do you
get in front of people let them know
they should use this app how do you get
route around censorship of apps
ultimately the you know I think we've
seen that and again this is what Snowden
said is is you know math works you know
the fundamental premise we have has not
been broken or shaken everything is
sound that we're building upon there
might be seven open SSL vulnerabilities
tonight then I need to scamper home and
deal with
but otherwise you know the we just need
to do more and we need to continue to
spread the word and ensure people have
access to these tools in an affordable
way that's not just on it the latest
smartphone let me make you Jonathan's a
trained for a moment here and and push a
little bit on this App Store idea that
there's a couple of things that we often
talk about when we talk about security
in this space one of the big things we
talk about is users and usability and
certainly getting to the point where you
can go and say download this app and
make me secure is an appealing place to
be what's the barrier that we're having
at this point with with Android and
Apple app stores as far as trying to
bring something like already in the
market I mean in the Google world there
isn't it there is very little barrier
and it's it's we have this great
opportunity where we can just put it's
gotten with so much better than
previously with with Java phones for
instance and telcos so that we can put
our app in the App Store and it's
published globally instantly and Apple
you know is a gatekeeper and they
require more of a process but what we've
seen now is that in places like China
you know they've they've removed apps
based on local requests so there's local
censorship of apps and people don't
aren't impacted in the same way that if
there was censorship of DNS or the web
you know and you hear oh this app isn't
available in this country it doesn't
seem quite as bad as when a website's
blocked the you know and increasingly
these are going back to the trust issue
from a user perspective people trust the
Apple App Store because it seems safer
less viruses right Apple sells this
trust us will protect you and I don't
want to dismiss the users the users
stake in this you know I don't want them
to say I don't want to say well you're a
bunch of idiots because you're trusting
a sensor system there is some value to
the fact that Apple provides a good
service so it's that balance between
what the user needs and benefits from in
terms of curation versus the
you know but it's a bit of a Liberty
versus security debate within the
AppStore world so thanks for that Jill I
I want to tell a story to ask you a
question okay so a little bit more than
a decade ago I was in Cairo meeting with
an Egyptian human rights organization
the organization for personal rights you
and I both know that personal rights in
the Arab context translates as gay
rights and I was there to do a security
training to figure out why they weren't
using tor and PGP despite the fact that
we trained them three or four times to
use tor and PGP and the folks there
explained that they weren't going to
bother using any of the silly security
software because everybody knew that the
entire internet traffic was routed
through seven computers in the basement
of the White House and that the
president just read everything that was
coming through and I said that's crazy
that's totally absurd how could that
possibly happen and then of course what
we found out this year is that more or
less that's what happened so the
question that I want to ask as a fellow
activists in this space is how do we
deal with what I've started referring to
a security Niall ism now that we figured
out just how hard this is how difficult
it is to actually keep a channel secure
and how to keep a targeted individual
able to use these sorts of tools that
have been so important in the Arab world
and really around the whole world how is
an organization like EF f dealing with
this sort of post Snowden climate of
security nihilism sure yes I mean
there's there's you know I do some
trainings in the field and we're
developing a project called surveillance
self-defense that's going to answer a
lot of the questions that people have
how do you use the Guardian projects
apps things like that and when I talk to
people I get these two different
perspectives one is the Silicon Valley
and we saw in the past couple of weeks
mark Andreas and Robert Scoble both
going well no justice keying the privacy
advocates oh you guys are useless you
know this is if we're in the post
privacy world and I I words can't
express how I feel about them and then
on the other side of it though you've
got the privacy
lists the folks who say you know this is
pointless everything's being watched
anyway or even you know to another
degree I'm not gonna use tor because
that makes me a target in my country
which is true if you don't have enough
users and so how do we deal with that I
think is a big and serious question that
I can't answer completely but some of
the things that you know we've been
doing are looking at it okay well with
journalists for example a lot of
journalists you know are used to taking
enormous risks and are willing to take
an enormous personal risk but maybe
aren't realizing that it's not just
about them it's also about their source
it's also about the people they're
communicating with and that's been true
for a lot of the other folks that I've
talked to that kind of have that
approach in the Arab world and elsewhere
you know I find the other side of the
coin actually more difficult to deal
with when you have these strong powerful
white male voices from Silicon Valley
telling you that privacy is not
important
and their voices you know are being
heard over our voices so I actually find
that side of the coin much more
difficult but yeah I mean the privacy
nihilists are real too and I think that
you know the ease of use and usability
and the the improved user interfaces of
some of these products make it a lot
easier for me to get people to use them
for me to be able to say okay we're not
talking about PGP anymore because PGP is
hard Tech secure or the Guardian
projects apps not that hard I don't mean
to say that to belittle anyone that does
find them difficult and I'm happy to sit
down with you if you do and help you
through it but nonetheless I think that
this is making it a lot better for us so
let's move into technocratic white male
privilege space and and actually talk
about this question of how online
culture commercial culture may be sort
of tied into all of this one of the
responses to some of the Snowden
revelations has been what's the problem
you're all telling everyone everything
on Facebook anyway why would you care
now that it's government instead of the
private sector and Bruce Schneier has
this wonderful line that I actually find
myself repeating again and again which
is that surveillance has become
the business model for the internet that
almost all of these large platforms that
were sort of paying attention to we have
this very uneasy uncomfortable situation
with them in which we are giving up an
enormous amount of data to have ads
targeted to ourselves in exchange for
free services is there a connection
between giving up certain amounts of
privacy and target ability in commercial
spaces and the fact that while in a room
like this we can talk about a post
Snowden world but in terms of mainstream
America we may not have had this sort of
outrage and reaction that some of us
were sort of expecting from this did we
somehow set up government surveillance
by normalizing corporate surveillance
and and what can we what can we do about
it well I'm just gonna give a quick
answer because I want to hear what they
have to say as well but basically you
know first off there's a difference
between you know I live my life pretty
loudly on the internet everything's got
my real name and there's a difference
between the things that I say on
Facebook or Twitter and the private
communications that I have with my
sources my family whatever the second
thing is a lot of people make the
argument that social media companies
don't have an army to back them so their
surveillance is not as bad
well first off that's not true they do
have an army to back them they're in bed
with the NSA but second so what that
doesn't mean that we should be handing
over everything to them that doesn't
mean that you know just like governments
can change in an instant so can
companies and you know I don't know if
we're talking about the sort of hostile
takeover of Google's scenario or
whatever scenario but nevertheless I
don't want companies to have that
information and that should be a choice
yeah I mean you know this is where I
guess play the some crypto communists
centralized European on panel which
because I am that you know I mean one of
the things I've been I've lived in
America now for years and one of the
principal cultural difference is really
the an idea of kind of centralized some
sort of centralized power and alternate
kind of balance to if you like the
corporate world and really living in the
genuine sort free market and market
economy where
we're in America the you know commercial
commercial rules are you know sort of
the rules you know you have a public
sphere here which is basically as Clay
Shirky sees and lots of people have said
you know it's really a private spiff
sphere which tolerates free speech you
know what we're seeing in Europe at the
moment is a kind of pushback against the
white male kind of technocratic voices
not necessarily the most intelligent
pushback perhaps you know kind of which
is you know this idea of you know let's
the the rights be forgotten ruling which
came down a couple of weeks ago from the
Justice which which is really about sort
Ain things off of the internet and
saying that if you if you don't like the
way that your results render and it's
not in the public interest you can have
them removed from Google's cache if you
if you if you ask if you ask nicely all
through the correct channels so so it's
kind of interesting here because you
have very tiny like regulation here is
small and you know we're entering in
global market we're actually that kind
of like regulation is much more kind of
from Center in in different markets and
I kind of think that you know one of the
balances to this enormous kind of court
called priming it's it's kind of an
incredible things it is you know it
American public media is Google you know
it is Facebook it is shaping the way
that the world communicates with each
other it is imposing and I say this
nicely you know American stands as a
free speech on the rest of the world you
know and actually in many parts of the
world it's not that simple so you know
we have we have to have more than you
know we have to have I think you know a
really engaged intelligent conversation
with government we're not going to get
that until you have more kind of
engagement if you like sit on the ground
I'm actually so I would I push back that
isn't in that I'm surprised at how many
people here have paid attention to the
NSA story if I go by Roenick if you go
back to the UK if I go back to the UK
had almost no airplay there whatsoever
you know almost none and one of the
reasons is that something like you
noticed April across to the BBC it's not
staples to be you know licensee fur has
not really run run with the stories the
other press outlets have not run with
the story people have kind of gone we
sort of knew it anyway we need more
vivid illustrations of why this is
really kind of and you don't need those
vivid illustrations right in in in in
countries where people are in jail
because you know because they are
vulnerable but but here I think that you
know I think that the debate is really
important that kind of you know Snowden
was a series of events that pushed it
out the stops got it kind of beyond I
would say Washington New York San
Francisco but it needs you know there is
a danger that it kind of fizzles out if
you like there's a good as a ground
roots issue and as you say people just
say well this is this is kind of an
expedient role I would I just like to
see more people kind of picking this up
as a political issue because we do need
regulation and we do need kind of some
cuts of governance in this area you know
it's is I can't see otherwise how you
count balance what's essentially kind of
you know that the the corporate might of
you know a handful of companies in
Silicon Valley well so Nathan I want to
ask about is there a hope that the
corporations are going to sort of move
around to our side are we likely to end
up with secure communications software
you know for our phones there was a
moment in time where some of us thought
that Skype was perhaps a step forward
and and and might be harder to tap then
existing telecommunications that's
proven absolutely not to be the case it
is this a moment where we might see
someone move into the commercial
marketplace or is it going to have to be
non-governmental organisations activist
organizations like your project that are
sort of trying to figure out how to
create what turns out to be very
difficult to build and very powerful
software so in continuing a non-us sort
of centric view of this problem one of
the apps that I engage with a lot is
called WeChat wage equation from China
you know this was adopted rapidly over
the course of last year by Tibetans
and you know hundreds and hundreds of
millions of users around the world and
now it's being adopted in India of all
places at a crazy rate and so we chat
being that every message you send goes
through you know Shanghai or Beijing
data centers and is subject to filtering
and monitoring by the you know people
that we usually associate with closing
down borders from people trying to get
out as opposed to inversely
surveillancing they're sort of my one of
my mortal enemies like I hate WeChat you
know they're just like making my life so
much I know I was at a meeting where
researcher had had started unpacking the
code and looking at the guts of WeChat
and they decided to surprise me by
saying you know and we looked in the
source code and it found that turns out
they're using Guardian project software
in WeChat so we chat uses our encrypted
database software sequel cipher why did
the Chinese app company employ a
database encryption in their mobile app
I think because they cared about
protecting their users and they didn't
want messages to be hacked or copied and
I think there's there are strange
bedfellows when it comes to users and
corporations and data and we're starting
to see these sort of post national
interest which is sound scary but it's
also useful in that if there's an
alliance between users and the services
that supports them that goes against
sort of government surveillance then yes
you know and we're starting to see
Google doing end-to-end encryption for
that reason and I think it's very likely
we can see someone like $0.10 or you
know do that so for us we really see
ourselves as reference designing we have
an app called obscure cam that
automatically blurs faces when you take
a picture we want every camera app to
have that feature harlow leads a project
called informa cam which allows you to
actually trust a photo is not
manipulated when you see it and verify a
chain of custody so that when there's a
photo of a shark swimming down the East
River in New York you can tell if it's
real or not so all of these things are
big ideas and feature designs and
reference designs and we need industry
to adopt them and we need the news
industry to adopt these tools and
journalists to adopt them as this is the
standard practice for
sources are verifying media so I I think
that concept of of the toolkit or of the
library that it's out there and it's
becomes pieces that other organizations
can use is incredibly powerful and and
one thing sort of implicit in your
comment Nate it's that one of the
reasons why we'd like large corporations
to do this is that the scaling problem
around these tools is really really hard
it's been hard to get to the point where
enough people are using tor that it
serves as cover traffic rather than as a
clear sign that you have something to
hide but you can imagine if tor was part
of the Mac operating system or Windows
or so on Firefox or that's right you
know that starts getting very very
interesting as far as sort of where we
figure out where to go on this I wanted
to come back to something that Emily
said because it it I I thought your
observation that not only are we in a
privately held public sphere but we're
in a privately held public sphere that
works on US laws whether we mean it to
or not is really interesting I was in
Myanmar earlier this year Julian
happened to be there as well this is
what happens when you go to a lot of the
same conferences but we were bizarrely
enough at a conference of freedom of
expression in Yangon which is not a
place that I would have expected to be
but young gone has actually made some
real progress around freedom of
expression and I was talking to a lot of
independent journalists and a lot of
activists about the internet and I found
out two things one was the Internet is
Facebook in in Myanmar right now you
don't search on Google because no one
knows what Google is you search on
Facebook because that's all you know and
then the second thing was that my
activist friends wanted Facebook to be
censoring posts and they very
specifically wanted to be going after
ethnic incitement and hate speech and
this for me as an American who is very
very interested in freedom of expression
was incredibly uncomfortable I found
myself sort of sitting there and saying
but guys like you can't possibly trust
this government they're gonna use this
against you at some point fairly soon
the flipside to which was people sort of
saying look if this is going to be our
public sphere we need it to operate a
way other than its operating right now
because this is going to blow up and
people are gonna get hurt or sort of get
killed from this how do we have this
conversation if Rebekah is right and I
think Rebecca is right that the really
powerful actors in this space are the
internet hegemon they are the the
powerful platform companies they do a
great deal more regulation of speech
right now than formal regulators how do
we sort of open that conversation how do
look have a conversation that deals with
at least two points of view we have on
the panel where I know that Jill feels
really really strongly on freedom of
expression and and making sure that we
don't have censorship and I and I take
Emily to be making a point that some of
these standards may actually need to be
more local or if you don't want to take
that point I'll happily take that point
yeah well I you know I wouldn't you know
I would never stand against the American
stand of free speech you know it's
protected but but but you also have
First Amendment protections say I wish
you know you can't don't have another
places and also you know you kind of are
actually a pretty self censoring Society
as well you know and that there are
places where you know kind of free
speech really means can mean kind of you
know people living in fear of hate
speech and kind of you know organized
aggression and you know in more volatile
kind of situations and it's a really
it's really difficult because ultimately
we should definitely be working towards
this kind of you know more open standard
but you know the main thing is just to
get a debate where the major platform
companies will even acknowledge that
what they do is editorial so that's the
most important thing which is you know
you hear it time and time and time again
we're just take company they're not just
to take company and even if they were
everything they do is imbued with what
you might call you know kind of cultural
or editorial standards so you know when
we can't have this debate with them
until the leadership of those companies
and
Mark Zuckerberg's and she's a very Page
Sergey Brin's of this world will really
engage with it you know and not as
Jillian says just kind of go oh it's
over we're now into this phase you know
this is not glib phrase you know these
people have enormous power now over how
people live their lives you know and it
needs to be they need to be brought into
that discussion because I think that you
know that we can't nobody can pretend
now that it's not an editorial act to
tweak a news algorithm to include or
exclude kind of you know results from
from something that they show we
understand it's journalism job to
understand these systems as well as
these companies do and push against them
because you know they are they are new
systems of power that we have to hold to
account you know I think that the reason
that Snowden was so valuable was it was
the first time you began to get some
acknowledgement I mean I've seen Eric
Schmidt saying if you want to be safe on
the internet you just have to be very
careful what you put on there you know
they're not saying that anymore which is
that's one thing but we have to have
more active engagements from from from
from tech companies we really do and I
think the issue of ethnic violence or I
mean we've seen in China you know people
labeled as terrorists or local I think
we need to you know they're cracking
down on Tibetans and self-immolations
and and if you share the media online of
a self-immolation that is now punishable
and it's and so there there's ways that
that is used to persecute and and I and
I respect a society's need to sort of
have harmony our humans need to have
harmony and to have you know and but at
the same time you know yeah it is you
know what people one person labels this
terrorism is it freedom fighter of
course then you embrace the really
interesting idea a moment ago that
Tencent may actually sort of be on the
side of increased openness in this space
I wonder if I can get you to sort of
that not just about we shouldn't but
maybe also about Weibo yeah there well
again this idea that you know if
everyone used Twitter on the planet we
would all be happy but there's a there's
a draw of Chinese to these platforms
because they're native right and they're
national and they're local and there's
pride in that but I think at the same
time these companies are moving
internationally right and so Tencent
can't afford to have WeChat be seen as a
Chinese company right especially in
India and there's all these Indian
celebrities who are advertising WeChat
to the Indian population and so that you
know they want to be they see themselves
as Google as Twitter as these global so
I think there is a millennial generation
of tech companies perhaps that you know
that is has more future looking values
around you know having some private
communications that are maybe there's a
more nuance coming between the the
public sphere and the private and this
is the Weibo WeChat kind of balance
where it's like well you should be able
to say some things in WeChat you can't
say on Weibo so I I'm you know I think
there there is a technocratic hope that
you know or I meet Chinese developers on
github all the time right and github is
this great gathering of code and there's
there's some hope that we all have these
same perspectives what are what we
should do for the user and and that the
government's can get in the way of that
and so we should have ended equip tional
and all these things so I think as a new
form of international diplomacy maybe it
has impossibilities and you know I'm
hopeful that at Google i/o happening or
any other national gathering of
developers that they're you know you
sort of much like the internet task
force you put aside some of that
nationalism so that you can make the
internet work better so Jill you're
involved with these conversations
everyday with large Internet companies
as they try to figure out how they
navigate both constraint to the internet
censorship surveillance within different
foreign governments and also as they try
to think about what sort of controls
they're going to have on this space how
are how are you talking with these
different entities around these
questions around surveillance in
particular yeah so it's really tempting
for me to go off into the speech zone
but I'm not gonna do that
however I'll just give an example so
that I can try to transfer it back to
surveillance so if you saw over the past
couple weeks Twitter took down some
content at the behest of the Pakistani
government and then put it back up and
the reason that happened from all public
accounts is that the package the
Pakistani legal order was questionable
in nature
Pakistani groups were railing against
the decision etc and Twitter did the
right thing by putting it back up and
I'm we commended them yes I've commended
them on that decision today but this is
exactly the sort of thing that really
concerns me if you look at Facebook or
Twitter or Google's transparency reports
they're handing over data to governments
whether they have no offices and that
are not democratic and so Facebook for
example right in their transparency
report they give user data to the
Pakistani government and we don't know
what that is so sure maybe it's a murder
case and there's a law enforcement
request that is legitimate or maybe it's
not but it concerns me really that these
companies are making these decisions by
and large without any local expertise as
part of it and so while I can sort of
trust trust Twitter's judgment to you
know understand and correctly apply a
legal order from say Germany or the UK I
don't really trust their judgment
because really these are companies out
in Silicon Valley where this kind of
very arrogant error exists you know
everything we've got this right this is
how it goes and most of these companies
don't have particularly diverse policy
teams and so I think that that's one of
the big issues here is if you're dealing
with user requests for data if you're
dealing with that I mean these are you
know a form of surveillance in a way if
you're dealing with that sort of thing
you need to be consulting not just with
inner groups like the gni but with local
organizations in the country that you're
dealing with and I'd really at this
point don't trust these companies to get
that right so with these three
remarkable individuals on stage I want
to make sure that we have a chance to
open up a conversation the conversation
probably will not be completed during
this session but I am happy to take some
questions and I
see even before I'm rising with the
microphone Rebecca already has the hand
up so we're gonna give her pride a place
with the first question for other folks
who want to get thanks so much even
Nathan I was really intrigued by your
comments on Chinese companies and
Tencent Weibo and so on and it you know
I've also seen in some research I've
done that some of the Chinese companies
are making efforts around consumer
privacy and security against hackers and
sort of criminal attacks and so on but
do you feel have you seen any evidence
that these Chinese companies are pushing
back against data demands from Chinese
public security bureau and state
security bureau at all no and and I
think my developer optimism maybe is
getting ahead of what they're capable of
doing as companies within the Chinese
realm but I do think that they're not as
horrible as maybe they're made out to be
when it comes to the state of US
companies and and so I think there is
you know there's no transparency and we
continue to have reports from our
Tibetan groups of people that are
detained very frequently after posting
things on privately on WeChat so I
that's a very good clarification
question but the the fact that well I'm
gonna test what happens because we're
gonna be building on top of the WeChat
API soon so we'll see you know if they
block us right and and how I open their
API czar I think is will be an
interesting test so the floor is open
for questions regarding surveillance
regarding trust regarding the
transformation of journalism the tech
industry activism within this space I am
really happy to see the hands coming up
and I will work to get the Micra of the
different folks hi my name is Caitlin
and I work at WNYC my question is about
the sort of migration of journalists to
tech companies and the way that they've
created all these editorial positions
and I'm sort of it's an open-ended
question but what do you guys think the
responsibility of
journalists who make that migration is
to sort of change and tackle some of
these issues that you guys are talking
about yeah that's a great question I
think it's to advocate to educate
advocate internally and externally about
what what journalism actually is I mean
there's always a there's always a
problem when you are a journalist within
an organization which is intrinsically
not journalistic you know which is that
you are a low priority and particularly
if you're in a company which is you know
post IPO needs to kind of services
shareholders etc because journalism
isn't gonna make many of these companies
much money you know it's gonna actually
make it hard for them to make money
because you'll be they will be
supporting things which nobody wants to
hear which advertisers certainly don't
want to sit against you know it
introduces that but if you you know if
you do if you do hop the fence or
whatever and you know look there are
there is there are fantastic advantages
to having platforms like Twitter right
you know I advocate for it all the time
in my classrooms but I also say you know
be aware of how these systems work so I
do think that you know if if you really
want you know Facebook you know and it's
greatly have kind of really smart people
like the team with a very sick and and
Vivian Schiller now and so inside these
companies but you know that's kind of a
those are powerful positions now and I
think sort of advocating for what is
intrinsically journalistic versus
intrinsically commercial is a really
important part of that role I was going
to ask you talked about protecting
sources but there's a challenge now in
in getting a source how do you get a
government source now because and this
this may be more of a journalistic you
know question but who and the government
is going to talk to you if they know the
cell phones are tapped the emails are
tapped so is there a new way that you
operate just to even get sources now is
it more you've got to get out there and
palette pound the pavement or
what I'd like to hear from all on this
because I I think this is really a
question about trust and we're sort of
all working with different populations
on this so Emily sorry to cut you off
just just very briefly Glen Townley
wrote a great report on this kind of
just briefing just sort of more or less
a couple of months after the Snowden
revelations came out which talked to
lots and lots of editors and national
security reporters that said exactly as
you say the problem here is not just
security around sources it's the fact
that nobody wants to talk you know and
that's a huge problem and you know
whilst you have the kind of arms race of
the Obama administration pursuing
through you know kind of fairly ancient
kind of espionage laws etc leakers and
sources you're gonna have that problem
and that's that's a huge different area
that we need to address because it's not
about security it's about culture and
I'll short answer one Barton Gellman I
think has sort of the best operational
security in the business and should be
recognized as such and just you know he
can tell you how he communicates
securely and what he does and platforms
like global leaks and secure drop and
and platforms that news agencies can put
in place that raise the bar for the way
they accept submissions of content and
such that they they protect that their
sources by default so I think there's
just you know upgrade your skills it's
possible there's free tools there's free
apps and there's colleagues who are
already you know the the freedom of the
press foundation colleagues who are
already engaging with with this as you
know providing that entry point for new
sources I agree with that I was gonna
say just about what Nathan said but I
guess I'll take it one step further and
say that and put out a public call for
these wonderful platforms like secure
drop in global leaks to take miss stuff
internationally we're seeing a lot of US
media organizations adopt these
technologies and that's where the
outreach has been but I think that these
technologies need to now be adopted by
journalism organizations around the
world hi um quick question I'm new to
newsroom things but I find the the idea
of operational security for journalists
and new in newsrooms absolutely
fascinating however in my discussions
with you know people at various
newsrooms usually in like IT and
security there
despite the myriad options that people
have they actually do not recommend
anything officially because of course
the stakes are way too high I was
wondering if you are in the newsrooms
that you had been in were there specific
instances when there were like practices
that were 100 percent sanctioned taught
and you know yeah exactly
well I mean two things when I was at the
Guardian we first of all you know there
was nothing that was the system at and I
think this is not just the Guardian it's
and other newsrooms I've been in as well
I think there were certain practices
that individual reporters practiced I
think that getting it kind of
institutionally supported was harder and
I think we're now entering a new phase
and you know secure drop is again one of
those kind of tools which you now hear
talked about an institution 11 that's
actually an important distinction to
make between individual OPSEC for
reporters and actually how journalistic
institutions say how we can adopt what's
good which we agree on you know what are
the standards and have a conversation
you know among themselves so in general
you know there was that the the the
standards of security and the types of
tools were restricted that the other
thing that's concerning is restricted to
a tiny number of reporters because it
was always felt well outside that
Charmed Circle nobody else will need
that level of security and you know
these tools are hard sometimes they're
not they've got a lot easier in the last
couple of years since I've not been in
you in newsrooms but we we need we need
kind of you know more progress on that
as well but also threat modeling I think
that sometimes it isn't possible to
guarantee safety so you need to threat
model and your journalists need to think
through who am i exposing to danger here
what can I do about it what can't you
know it's not all about tools some of it
is also just about thought process and
about you know not you know what we call
you know low-tech solutions as well and
that was not routinely taught and that's
where kind of places like no place I
work J schools have got kind of you know
really up their game and and close that
skills gap yeah I'm gonna use my
favorite line here and say that um
encryption works but encryption tools
are like condoms they're 99% you know
effective when used properly but really
I mean that's a thing that's another
thing that really freaks me out is the
idea that of people pushing a certain
tool as being the savior or NSA proof if
you see that term run in the opposite
direction I think that I mean yes we use
a whole bunch of different things dff
and I think that all of these tools are
really important but I don't want anyone
to ever think that every that these are
gonna be perfect solutions and go back
to nihilism point which I didn't get to
comment on I mean one of the places I
gained inspiration and hope is from my
Tibetan colleagues who you know after 50
years of occupation and these odds
against a huge state power and the
greatest surveillance state that on
record the you know they're still
optimistic and and ingenuitive and find
humor and find solutions and practical
ways to move forward
so if you're feeling like you can't do
anything or you know some of the work
we're doing with the safe travels online
campaign is meant more to give you
inspiration to try and to take small
steps you know and that's what keeps me
going and and that you know it's not
about complexity it's about you know
each in intuition and little decisions
you make every day so hi my name is
solarium I work in C cell I am
interested in your views on tour so tour
I have a machine that has tails on it
and it's unusable it takes too long to
load there is tons of websites that have
been blocked and the worst part of it is
that even though it's very good for
certain kind of aspects 80% of my users
on tours they use it for illegal
purposes so having this kind of privacy
within without accountability has this
kind of side effect so this kind of
tools while maybe effect
if they might cause more harm than good
in some other places Nathan I think
we're gonna make us answer that one
first I have as a developer tour I feel
I'll admit my bias
you know I the the numbers of illegal or
non illegal used
I mean tour is illegal lots of places in
the world and and I know that it tales
itself if you're trying to use it for
day-to-day activities it it can slow
down I think finding ways that tools
like tor can be useful to you and in
day-to-day life is is a good thing so
saying you know you may not need
ultimate security of tales I run or bots
on tour on my phone and tablets and I
run Twitter through it and so I said you
know I'm gonna run all my Twitter
traffic through tor and that's a great
way to use tor because it doesn't feel
slow and people aren't tracking when
you're using Twitter and that's what
works for me I don't use tails all of
the time so I think there's you know you
have to find what works for you you have
to find where the technology is viable
and and I think that the idea that you
know I'll push back and say tor is not
slow and toward I can show you streaming
video over tor and and and all sorts of
fast usable ways to use tor I use
Facebook over tor and Google so I think
ultimately saying it's not black or
white and finding one way that you can
use a privacy enhancing technology in
your life today right now that works for
you is a first step and don't just throw
the baby out with the bath water because
tails was too much to start with it's
like saying we're gonna switch to I'm
gonna have no bags and full organic I'm
gonna grow my vegetables and you know
switching your diet overnight it's not
going to happen so so I'll speak to that
I mean I was gonna say tor
you know I I recognize that there are
places in the world where tor is nearly
impossible to use Lebanon is a very good
example of this and that's I know a
thing that they're very conscious of but
in terms of the illegal use okay so I
mean I guess substitute cars I'm sorry
to use this analogy carbon
I'm still going with this one I'm sorry
um cars cause pollution they kill people
all the time they run over animals
so let's outlaw cars because they can be
used for harm I think that it's true
sure torque can be used for harm but I
think that the incredibly important uses
of it whether we're talking about
activists in Egypt or people in the US
who are looking up things about their
health that they need privacy for any
whatever the reason I think that the
good use is I don't I don't want to say
outweigh the bad because that's what
life is it's always about trade-offs but
I think that the that tor is incredibly
important for all of those uses despite
the fact that it can also be used for
illegal purposes leo happening or any
other national gathering a developer's
that there you know you sort of much
like the internet task force you put
aside some of that nationalism so that
you can make the internet work better so
Jill you're involved with these
conversations every day with large
Internet companies as they try to figure
out how they navigate both constraint to
the Internet censorship surveillance
within different foreign governments and
also as they try to think about what
sort of controls they're going to have
on this space how are how are you
talking with these different entities
around these questions around
surveillance in particular yeah so it's
really tempting for me to go off into
the speech zone but I'm not gonna do
that
however I'll just give an example so
that I can try to transfer it back to
surveillance
so if you saw over the past couple weeks
Twitter took down some content at the
behest of the Pakistani government and
then put it back up and the reason that
that happened from all public accounts
is that the Pakistan Pakistan illegal
order was questionable in nature
Pakistani groups were railing against
the decision etc and Twitter did the
right thing by putting it back up and
I'm we commended them if I've commended
them on that decision today but this is
exactly the sort of thing that really
concerns me if you look at Facebook or
Twitter or Google's transparency reports
they're handing over data to governments
where they have no offices and that are
not democratic and so Facebook for
example right in their transparency
report they give user data to
Pakistani government and we don't know
what that is so sure maybe it's a murder
case and there's a law enforcement
request that is legitimate or maybe it's
not but it concerns me really that these
companies are making these decisions by
and large without any local expertise as
part of it
and so while I can sort of trust trust
Twitter's judgment to you know
understand and correctly apply a legal
order from say Germany or the UK I don't
really trust their judgement because it
really these are companies out in
Silicon Valley where this kind of very
arrogant error exists you know
everything we've got this right this is
how it goes and most of these companies
don't have particularly diverse policy
teams and so I think that that's one of
the big issues here is if you're dealing
with user requests for data if you're
dealing with enamine these are you know
form of surveillance in a way if you're
dealing with that sort of thing you need
to be consulting not just with inner
groups like the gni but with local
organizations in the country that you're
dealing with and I'd really at this
point don't trust these companies to get
that right so with these three
remarkable individuals on stage I want
to make sure that we have a chance to
open up a conversation the conversation
probably will not be completed during
this session but I am happy to take some
questions and I can see even before I'm
rising with the microphone Rebecca
already has the hand up so we're gonna
give her pride of place with the first
question for other folks who want to get
thanks so much
Nathan I was really intrigued by your
comments on Chinese companies and
Tencent Weibo and so on and it you know
I've also seen in some research I've
done that some of the Chinese companies
are making efforts around consumer
privacy and security against hackers and
sort of criminal attacks and so on but
do you feel have you seen any evidence
that these Chinese companies are pushing
back against data demands from Chinese
public security bureau and state
security bureau at all no and and I
think my developer optimism maybe is
getting ahead of what they're capable of
doing as companies within the Chinese
realm
but I do think that they're not as
horrible as maybe they're made out to be
when it comes to the state of US
companies and and so I think there is
you know there's no transparency and we
continue to have reports from our
Tibetan groups of people that are
detained very frequently after posting
things on privately on WeChat so I
that's a very good clarification
question but the the fact that well I'm
going to test what happens because we're
gonna be building on top of the WeChat
API soon so we'll see you know if they
block us right and and how open their
api's are I think is will be an
interesting test so the floor is open
for questions regarding surveillance
regarding trust regarding the
transformation of journalism the tech
industry activism within this space I am
really happy to see the hands coming up
and I will work to get the mic around
the different folks hi my name is
Caitlin I work at WNYC my question is
about the sort of migration of
journalists to tech companies and the
way that they've created all these
editorial positions and I'm sort of it's
an open-ended question but what do you
guys think the responsibilities of
journalists who make that migration is
to sort of change and tackle some of
these issues that you guys are talking
about yeah that's a great question I
think it's to advocated educating that
vaque internally and externally about
what what journalism actually is I mean
there's always a there's always a
problem when you are a journalist within
an organization which is intrinsically
not journalistic you know which is that
you are a low priority and particularly
for your in a company which is you know
post IPO needs to kind of services
shareholders etc because journalism
isn't gonna make many of these companies
much money you know it's gonna actually
make it hard for them to make money
because you will be either they will be
supporting things which nobody wants to
hear which advertisers certainly don't
want to sit against you know it
introduces that but if you you know if
you do if you do hop the fence or
whatever and you know look there are
family there is no there are fantastic
advantages to having platforms like
Twitter I you know I advocate for it all
the time in my classrooms but I also say
you know be aware of how these systems
work so I do think that you know if if
you really want you know Facebook you
know and it's great that you have kind
of really smart people like four teams
of research and and Vivian Schiller now
and inside these companies but you know
that's kind of like those are powerful
positions now and I think sort of
advocating for what is intrinsically
journalistic versus intrinsically
commercial is a really important part of
that role I was gonna ask you talked
about protecting sources but there's a
challenge now in in getting a source how
do you get a government source now
because and this this may be more of a
journalistic you know question but who
and the government is going to talk to
you if they know the cell phones are
attacked the emails are tapped so is
there a new way that you operate just to
even get sources now is it more you've
got to get out there and palette pound
the pavement or what I'd like to hear
from all on this because I think this is
really a question about trust and we're
sort of all working with different
populations on this so Emily sorry to
cut you off you want to make sure just
very briefly Len town he wrote a great
report on this kind of just a briefing
just sort of more or less a couple of
months after the Snowden revelations
came out which talked to lots and lots
of editors and national security
reporters that said exactly as you say
the problem here is not just security
around sources it's the fact that nobody
wants to talk you know and that's a huge
problem and you know whilst you have the
kind of arms race of the Obama
administration pursuing through you know
kind of very ancient can espionage laws
etc leakers and sources you're going to
have that problem and that's that's a
huge different area that we need to
address because it's not about security
it's about culture
and I'll sure to answer one Barton
Gellman I think has sort of the best
operational security in the business and
should be recognized as such and just
you know he can tell you how he
communicates securely and what he does
and platforms like global leaks and
secure drop and and platforms that news
agencies can put in place that raise the
bar for the way they accept submissions
of content and such that they they
protect that their sources by default so
I think there's just you know upgrade
your skills it's possible there's free
tools there's free apps and there's
colleagues who are already you know the
the freedom of the press foundation
colleagues who are already engaging with
with this as you know providing that
entry point for new sources I agree with
that I was gonna say just about what
Nathan said but I guess I'll take it one
step further and say that and put out a
public call for these wonderful
platforms like secure drop in global
leaks to take this stuff internationally
we're seeing a lot of US media
organizations adopt these technologies
and that's where the outreach has been
but I think that these technologies need
to now be adopted by journalism
organizations around the world hi good
question I'm new to newsroom things but
I find the the idea of operational
security for journalists and new in
newsrooms absolutely fascinating however
in my discussions with you know people
at various newsrooms usually in like IT
and security there
despite the myriad options that people
have they actually do not recommend
anything officially because of course
the stakes are way too high I was
wondering if you are in the newsrooms
that you had been in were there specific
instances when there were like practices
that were 100 percent sanctioned taught
and you know yeah exactly
well I mean two things when I was at the
Guardian we first of all you know there
was nothing that was the system and I
think that this is not just the Guardian
it's an other newsrooms I've been in as
well I think there were certain
practices that individual reporters
practiced I think that getting it
institutionally supported was harder and
I think we're now entering a new phase
and you know secure droppers again one
of those kind of tools which you now
hear talked about an institution 11
that's actually an important distinction
to make between individual OPSEC for
reporters and actually how journalistic
institutions say how we can adopt what's
good which we agree on you know what are
the standards and have a conversation
you know among themselves so in general
you know there was the the the the
standards of security and the types of
tools were restricted that the other
thing that's concerning is restricted to
a tiny number of reporters because it
was always felt well outside that
Charmed Circle nobody else will need
that level of security and you know as
Jason said these tools are hard
sometimes they know they've got a lot
easier in the last couple of years since
I've not been in mute and newsrooms but
we need we need kind of you know more
progress on that as well but also threat
modeling I think that sometimes it isn't
possible to guarantee safety so you need
to threat model and your journalists
need to think through who am i exposing
to danger here what can I do about it
what can you know it's not all about
tools some of it is also just about
thought process and about you know not
you know load what we call some you know
low-tech solutions as well and that was
not routinely tool and that's where kind
of places like no place I work J schools
have got kind of you know really up
their game and and close that skills gap
yeah I'm gonna use my favorite line here
and say that um encryption works but
encryption tools are like condoms
they're 99% you know
effective when used properly but really
I mean that's a thing that's another
thing that really freaks me out is the
idea that of people pushing a certain
tool as being the savior or NSA proof if
you see that term run in the opposite
direction I think that I mean yes we use
a whole bunch of different things dff
and I think that all of these tools are
really important but I don't want anyone
to ever think that every that these are
gonna be perfect solutions and going
back to nihilism point which I didn't
get to comment on I mean one of the
places I gained inspiration
and hope it's from my Tibetan colleagues
who you know after 50 years of
occupation and these odds against a huge
state power and the greatest
surveillance state that on record the
you know they're still optimistic and
ingenuitive and find humor and find
solutions and practical ways to move
forward so if you're feeling like you
can't do anything or you know some of
the work we're doing with the safe
travels online campaign is meant more to
give you inspiration to try and to take
small steps you know and that's what
keeps me going and and that you know
it's not about complexity it's about you
know each in intuition and little
decisions you make every day so hi my
name is ilaria I work in CCL I am
interested in your views on tour so tour
I have a machinima test Hales on it and
it's unusable it takes too long to load
there is tons of websites that have been
blocked and the worst part of it is that
even though it's very good for certain
kind of aspects 80% of my users on tours
they use it for illegal purposes so
having this kind of privacy within
without accountability has this kind of
side effect so these kind of tools while
may be effective they might cause more
harm than good
in some other places Nathan I think
we're gonna make us answer that one
first I have as a developer tour I feel
I'll admit my bias you know the the
numbers of illegal or non illegal use I
mean tor is illegal lots of places in
the world and and I know that it tales
itself if you're trying to use it for
day-to-day activities it can slow down I
think finding ways that tools like tor
can be useful to you and in day to day
life is is a good thing so saying you
know you may not need ultimate security
of tales I run or bots on tour on my
phone and tablets and I run Twitter
through it and so I said you know I'm
gonna run all my Twitter traffic through
tor and that's a great way to use tor
because it doesn't feel slow and people
aren't tracking when you're using
Twitter and that's what works for me I
don't use tails all of the time so I
think there's you know you have to find
what works for you you have to find
where the technology is viable and and I
think that the idea that you know I'll
push back and say tor is not slow in
tort I can show you streaming video over
tor and and and all sorts of fast
useable ways to use tor I use Facebook
over tor and Google so I think
ultimately saying it's not black or
white and finding one way that you can
use a privacy enhancing technology in
your life today right now that works for
you is a first step and don't just throw
the baby out with the bath water because
tails was too much to start with it's
like saying we're gonna switch to I'm
gonna have no bags and full organic I'm
gonna grow my vegetables and you know
switching your diet overnight it's not
going to happen so so I'll speak to that
I mean I was gonna say tor you know I I
recognize that there are places in the
world where tor is nearly impossible to
use Lebanon is a very good example of
this and that's I know a thing that
they're very conscious of but in terms
of the illegal use okay so I mean I
guess substitute cars I'm sorry to use
this analogy cars I'm still going with
this one I'm sorry cars cause pollution
they kill people all the time they run
over animals
so let's outlaw cars because they can be
used for harm I think that it's true
sure torque can be used for harm but I
think that the incredibly important uses
of it whether we're talking about
activists in Egypt or people in the US
who are looking up things about their
health but they need privacy for any
whatever the reason I think that the
good use is I don't I don't want to say
outweigh the bad because that's what
life is it's always about trade-offs but
I think that the tour is incredibly
important for all of those uses despite
the fact that it can also be used for
illegal purposes so so one of the many
things we try to do at this conference
is we try to set up panels discussions
talks that are going to give us fodder
for discussion when we head out and have
drinks and have dead
and questions about where we go a tour
is definitely one of them but mija
Sophia's is always suggesting to me that
one of the jobs in life is to ask a good
question so I'm gonna ask him to sort of
close off our conversation by asking a
good question ooh I'll make sure I end
with my voice going up actually it's a
three one question for each of you
so Emily my surveys of journalists in
the u.s. suggest that at the moment the
number of American journalists using any
sort of secure communications is
somewhere between one and five percent
why is that what can we do about that
Gillian same question but related to
activists and Nathan my question for you
is who pays to develop these tools I'm a
big worrier about the adage that if
you're not paying for something online
that's because you're the product so you
you are giving away these tools for free
but shouldn't we be paying for them so
three fantastic questions let's start in
the order that they were delivered okay
well one five percent you know is
exactly where you would expect it to be
and I think the answer to that is
because American journalists haven't
felt the need to and they haven't been
aware of what the risks are or the
threats are and they haven't really seen
how this arc is going to progress
because they're busy people they've got
a lot of stuff to do you know they've
got a lot of stuff to do and this this
stuff gets in the way you know so you've
got lots of stories to kind of write
have you got time to stop and learn all
of this stuff you know this OPSEC stuff
that actually is it Rick you know you're
kind of like you're a local education
reporter that really doesn't really
matter to you
and I think that what we know now and
what Snowden is shown the light on is
that everybody needs to do this you know
because journalism needs its own
channels of communication you know as a
bar association meeting we're actually
very senior lawyer came up to me off was
mine oh my god I hadn't realized that of
course the people that we are
representing you know we
no client confidentiality now it's not
just journalists and this is the start
of an educational process so you know we
have to be really active in that as J
schools you know journalists have to be
really active it and in reporting it you
know and the technology community I hope
will be active in helping us you know
figure out what these problems are and
come up with some robust and easy to
adopt solutions okay so my answer I'm
gonna keep it short I think the first
thing is that the developers need to
listen to their constituents listen to
their users and take their feedback
seriously another thing is make these
tools multilingual start from that
premise don't assume that your user base
speaks English or can even if they do
that they can use the tool with English
instructions and then the third one I'm
gonna paraphrase an Egyptian friend of
mine and say that until these tools are
as easy to use as a toaster or remote
control a lot of people aren't going to
use them and so I think we're getting
there and I think that that's one of the
keys is make these things seamless to
integrate into your normal daily life
and you know in terms of who's paying
for this now and who should be paying
for it down the road you know we're
lucky right now to benefit from various
funding sources including Internet
freedom initiatives of the US government
through groups like the open Technology
Fund so your taxes are paying yes if
you're an American or if you're Dutch or
if you're a few other governments
Swedish made the night news foundation
gave us a generous grant for work on
informa campus of foundations and Ford
and OSI and other groups so foundations
have taken an interest in this and Eric
Schmidt himself gave us some funding and
you know I think that can that can go on
for a while that can go on for a certain
period of time but it can't go on
forever and and and we need to you know
I mean Mozilla you know I need to talk
more with Mozilla and Apache and you
know they've figured out really
fascinating ways to get lots of money
from corporations and donations and and
I think you know ultimately I'm really
excited to see what someone like silent
circle is attempting to create a
business model around privacy and
security
unfortunately the minute you go that
route you ten
start prioritizing corporations and
military and kind of not the people that
I really is to do that work and I'm not
I want to help people that maybe can't
pay or don't have a credit card so I I'm
I'm looking for a longer-term plan and
help with that and and I believe it
again mozilla apache linux other web
foundation i'm inspired by those groups
because they've proven you can do this
for 20 years and and more than just my
two or three year grant horizon in my
head so let's get a round of applause
for our very very smart and engaged and
extremely helpful panelists here and i
think they're all around for dinner and
drinks and i help you install apps well
so if you want to continue this either
on the geeky level of what should i do
or on the higher level of what does this
mean about trust what does this mean
more broadly these are three terrific
people to connect with and in general
please keep in mind one of the big
reasons we do this is the hope that we
can spark some interesting conversations
and maybe collaborations which is why at
this point there is an open bar before
dinner so please head on out thank you
all for a really long informative but
wonderful day and thanks for hanging in
with us and have a wonderful evening